it's a dieter update now a regular
unemployment insurance claimant says he
wants other ui claimants to be
heard in the supreme court he went on to
say his past
work experience may help the court joe
mohler now joins us live he spoke to the
man
and he's here to explain joe
well stephen cohen says he believes he
has some insight that might help the
supreme court when it comes to an appeal
that's going on right now from his work
experience to
filing himself for unemployment he says
the language being used on the dieter
website is
confusing for some based on 14 years of
experience of dealing with
most pieces of theater
i can put in english and i had to do
that at medicaid all the time
stephen cohen filed for regular
unemployment insurance thursday he
shared a drought with eight news now of
the amicus brief he intends to file with
the nevada supreme court
this brief is a document showing a
different perspective that he believes
will help
it shows that the same problems
that are happening to pua folks which
may end
in a little over a week unless congress
acts
are also happening to regular ui folks a
months ago an appeal was filed in the
supreme court regarding a decision made
in the pain versus dieter case that is
ongoing in district court regarding pool
claims cohen says he has worked with
several state systems including medicaid
in the past and says the way the website
directions and questions are written
cause confusion
so if we had the information
consistently messaged
from unemployment
in a language that any person can
understand
we wouldn't even be in court at all he
says the next hearing is at the end of
the month
he says a lot of the issues with the
system need to be fixed on a state level
and he wants the court to see that
i think that a lot of it
whichever court's hands are going to be
tied
until the legislature fixes some of the
problems that i identified
in the last district court hearing
regarding that pua case dieter was
ordered to pay those poor claimants who
had their payments stopped
by wednesday of next week we'll be
staying on top of that case you can stay
with us for the very latest
reporting live joe mohler 8 news now